The correct answer is: The parameter doesn't appear at all on the URL.
Let's try that out in the browser to see it, for real.
So here we are in our browser; I click Submit,
with the checkbox unchecked,
and there is no "q" parameter in the URL. Simple enough.
Now--when I'm writing Server site software
to look at these values,
I usually check for the "q" parameter equaling "on"
and anything different from that means it's "off".
That's because I don't believe that all browsers
are going to behave quite the same here.
I know "on" is "on"--but, maybe it says "this string off"--who knows.
So I always just check for one case,
and the default case will just be "off".